there's an old story about how to catch
a monkey in case any of you aren't
interested in how to catch a monkey
now you know you're gonna know how to do
it first you have to take a large narrow
necked jar just large enough in diameter
at the top for a monkey to put its hand
inside then you have to fill it partway
with rocks so it's too heavy for the
monkey to carry then you scatter some
treats near the jar to attract them and
you put some inside inside the narrow
neck jar a monkey will come along if
you're lucky and grab the you know
goodies but he'll want the ones inside
the jar too so then put his hand in
there and grab what's in there and if
you've set up your monkey trap properly
then he won't be able get his hand out
because he's got the goodies not without
unclenching his hand not without
relinquishing what he already has the
monkey coucher can just walk over and
just pick up the monkey because the
monkey isn't into the whole sacrifice
thing because he's just a monkey you
know and so you can catch him as a
consequence of his own unregulated
hypothalamic desires you know and to be
what would you say charitable to the
monkey if you put out candy or something
like that's like how often does a monkey
get candy he's probably a little more
motivated than you are to not let go but
you get the point
the monkey catcher can just walk over to
the jar and pick up the monkey the
animal will not sacrifice the part for
the whole that's actually a pretty good
phrase hey it's the animal that will not
sacrifice the part for the whole perhaps
this story is apocryphal but as an
eccentric psychology professor once told
me fiction lies to you in the most truth
in the most truthful possible manner
something valuable given up ensures
future prosperity something valuable
sacrificed pleases the Lord those are
equivalent statements ones more
articulated I would say that's the first
statement and the second one is more
dramatic and more embedded in a
collective religious dream you might say
what's most valuable and best sacrificed
well obviously
that depends on the culture and the time
what is at least emblematic of that a
choice cut of meat well if you're a
herdsmen for example that that's a big
deal with I mean generally speaking
throughout human history meat has been a
very valuable commodity as it is by the
way among chimpanzees chimpanzees hunt
they like to hunt colobus monkeys and
you know they'll they'll basically start
eating the damn monkey alive they weigh
about 40 pounds despite the fact that
the thing is screaming away and that's
pretty interesting because one of the
things that indicates is that male
monkeys that male chimps they're the
ones that do the hunting aren't really
inhibited that much when they're in
hunter mode by what you might describe
as empathy and there's certain elements
of human behavior that are reminiscent
of that you see that sort of thing
emerged now and then in human
battlefields when groups of men seemed
to abandon all internal regulation
whatsoever to a degree that makes you
wonder if internal regulation even
exists